[Musik]
mein name ist luca herzlich willkommen
hier heute zu einem neuen blog meine
damen und herren im letzten block habe
ich 24 stunden vegan gelebt
nice
vor einigen tagen habe ich mich in dem
blockbuster ist lustig gemacht weil die
man hier trägt und viele leute meinte
haye bleibt jedoch lässt ahnen müssen
sich bewegen dem handy ist aber sicher
deswegen entschuldigung ich entschuldige
mich beim handels- und ihr seht jedoch
bereits im titel eingeblendet was im
heutigen video passieren wird und zwar
werden juden ich in einen baumarkt
fahren hier in so einen kleinen aufpreis
barren packen und in diesem pool kommen
plastikbälle und anstalten also eine
brille bart partie in meinem wohnzimmer
soll das ganze allerdings passiert
machen wir uns erstmal
lampen sind schon da ist dran sein und
nicht machen oder außen kenntlich machen
und garten ganz einfach wieder anmachen
allerdings kommen wir nun zu dem thema
der damen und herren das wetter kommen
wir nun zu dem thema warum wir dieses
video wahrscheinlich überhaupt der fall
angeklickt hat und zwar um mich sondern
auf meine kommen wir nun zu dem thema
wie dieses video angeklickt hat und was
auch ein zettel steht ich habe oben ein
wohnzimmer wo man kochen kann wo ich
fernsehe gucke und zweiter ordnung meine
kauf stehen ich habe allerdings auch
dieses zimmer ihren was irgendwie
irgendwann zwischen zimmer ist wo ich so
ein bisschen mucke mache und
sonnencremes oder dieses silber in den
nicht so ernst unnötig ist und ich erst
als er wirklich ein bisschen mehr
verlesen wollte bisschen chillen wurde
heißt es ich echt bescheiden eigentlich
gedacht mit vorschnell irgendwelche
liegestühle kaufen die ich dann in die
halle verlegt haben sie mal nach draußen
gucken kann kaufe ich mir einen auf das
waren pool und tage in denen die 250 500
der plastikbälle und dann kann man darin
schildert sich aber es wurde aber ich
weiß allerdings finde ich diese idee
einfach nicht verrückte sich hier sind
beide partien zu stellen also sondern
auch das mit bällen
ich glaube gar nicht mit anderen brunnen
wir fahren jetzt ins bauhaus und schaut
euch also kann ich was ich kaufen will
ich hätte nicht gedacht dass die so
krass viele aufblasbare pools haben das
ding ist halt das ist auch das waren
pulsuhren beziehungsweise ein
planschbecken was halt nicht so bereit
ist als nicht so interessen durchmesser
hat erreicht einer von 150 oder so
allerdings soll es relativ hoch sein
da sitzt man sich noch irgendwie anlegen
kann ich kann mich ja das passende
gefunden durchmesser von 150 m höhe von
50 zentimetern design
naja es erkennt cooler aussehen ich
meine das sieht auch ganz okay aus juli
müssen den bauern fahren und einkaufen
die frage führt die tabelle her 500
bunte bälle tabelle also das ist glaube
ich genau das was ich brauche freunde an
die kopf 25 euro
ob ich für den pool 9 euro zahle und für
525 bescheuert in der tat waren jetzt
täglich sechs sieben verschiedenen
schleifen von verschiedenen spielzeug
leben von verschiedenen baumärkten
fußstapfen wieder das wetter keine
werbung oder irgendwie für den namen
alles für solche dummen geblieben wir
sind angekommen bei toys'r'us freunde
irgendwie erinnert mich dass gerade an
dem vorletzten wir oder ich glaube dass
es nicht so ganz
jedoch sind wir dieses mal nicht hier um
reifen zu bauen oder des komischen
autohalterung vers sondern wir wollen
uns einen pool kaufen also ohne wasser
mit mit bällen bäume wir haben die
plastik welle gefunden und ich dachte
halt wirklich das so 250 gb mit dafür
bekommen dass es meine hand dass es
nichts die sache es halt der polier uns
kaufen wollten hatten durchmesser von
150 oder du bist nun ist 175 das heißt
wir sind am arsch den passenden pool auf
jeden fall gefunden freunde der telefon
sie hat maße von 152 x 74 die sind
eigentlich perfekt aber wir brauchen
dafür so krank viele bälle mit
sagenhaften muskelkater
wir haben zwei verschiedene pools zur
auswahl einmal den hier der hat auch im
durchmesser von 1 150 ist aber nur 30
zentimeter hoch und ist halt grund oder
serie der es auch 152 der durchmesser
aber 74 zentimeter hoch aber nur wegen
diesem komischen elefanten hier ich weiß
nicht ich habe besser aus nicht vom
greifen die sich nicht viel und ich
lasse jetzt instagram entscheiden welche
nicht kaufen soll nur wenige minuten
später an covers kamen bei der umfrage
heraus 86 prozent wollen den elefanten
ich war für das bunte ich weiß echt
nicht wie viele wir brauchen wir haben
uns doch etwas anders entschieden
freunde die bälle haben hier wirklich in
einer stückzahl von 250 einfach 30 euro
gekostet wir bräuchten sie 2200 euro nur
für diese blöden plastikbälle das heißt
wir werden jetzt auf jeden fall online
bestellen aber zumindest ahnen wir schon
mal ein pool
wir werden das war kein wasser einfüllen
aber wir haben schon mal am pult zu
hause angekommen freunde und ja ich habe
verkackt ich habe nur diesen pool kaufen
können keine ahnung hat und das im
schnitt jetzt dass gta hier über mich
machen allerdings bleibt uns jetzt keine
andere möglichkeit dieses ding einfach
mal aufzubauen
eigentlich ist das voll gut weil wir
dadurch halle
[Musik]
das doppel eigentlich ist es gar nicht
so schlecht dass wir jetzt nur diesem
pool kaufen konnten und so richtig weil
jetzt können wir den ganzen pool den
ganzen kernchen nach aufbauen können
das tier das im ermessen wie oh der ist
ja leider schon ausland wieder
rausgeflogen aber als deutscher davon
halte ich gar nichts sagen
krass das richtige tool insofern ist es
ist eigentlich gar nicht schlimm dass
wir nicht kaufen konnten weil ich meine
natürlich steht jetzt im sitzen nicht
mehr ich kaufe ein xxl bällebad machen
woods aber zusammensteht jetzigen was
gefehlt weil es nicht hingekriegt haben
aber nur die letzte möglichkeit
ich glaube das ganze jetzt mal aufbauen
aufblasen und wahrscheinlich findet ihr
denn überhaupt bestellen und dann
passiert zwar nicht in diesem blog meine
lieben freunde allerdings innerhalb der
nächsten block werde ich da nicht
wirklich selber lieber in meinem
wohnzimmer fertigstellen und jetzt post
will das ding erst mal auf
[Musik]
freunde wir machen das mal vor 2373
solchen speziellen fertig mit diesem
plan schmecken hier freunde gerät schon
die größe ist circa zwei meter irgendwas
mal 1 meter 50 euro wir können auf jeden
fall die beiden eben dann da drin sitzen
ich muss schon sagen auch rote welle ist
dieses ding echt geil werden mir
vorstellen dass ich das hier werde er
überhaupt meine terrasse stellen könnte
und wasser bevölkern hätte ich hier ein
pool an der stelle würde ich jetzt
allerdings auch missionen xxl bällebad
in meinem wohnzimmer erst mal beenden
das ding ist halt dass die ergebnisse in
etwa wände noch online bestellen ob das
ich will mich herzlich juli film also
hier haben wir jetzt wieder die 500
bunte bälle plastik bei der kinder bälle
babybett wie blöd kann man das
beschreiben die 500 stück hier bestellen
wir jetzt auf jeden fall vier mal
freunde das heißt wir sind dann auf
einen gesamtwert von 105 euro und ja
2000 bälle in dem kommunistisch und
wieder das ist unterhaltsamer konnten in
drei tagen zunächst noch in vier tagen
kommen 2000 spezifizierung zu freunde
erst richtig gehört
da kommt jetzt extra sonst peter
lieferwagen mit 2000 bällebad bällen für
mein xxl bällebad hier in meinem
wohnzimmer ich mein ja natürlich es gibt
viel viel größere delle bad berleburger
keine ahnung
in irgendwelchen keine ahnung was uns
dann andere youtuber was viel größeres
gemacht und sagt ich will nichts
größeres hier und ich will das auch
wenig nutzen weil wirklich ich habe auch
ein bisschen zu lesen ein bisschen mehr
so zu chillen und begabter wieder mal
nicht haut oben die echtheit gemütlich
ist und mein bett ist auch echt hat mit
licht fahren nachricht ist dass hier bin
ich mir ganz gute idee und willst nach
hinten wird das hier halt einfach lohnen
würde spielen ohne die wahrscheinlich
was zu essen
irgendwie bestellen wir dazu immer nur
durch julian gar noch unsere sachen
fertig gepackt weil wir jetzt in meiner
familie fahren werden da seht ihr
übrigens jude mit ihren sachen wir
werden jetzt meiner familie nach
bielefeld fahren primär weil ein guter
kollege von mir heute am geburtstag
eingeladen sind und deswegen werde ich
dieses noch nicht ganz bällebad aber
erst mal hier in köln stehen lassen mit
welcher sind gestellt das heißt so in 34
works werte dann sehen wir dieses
komplette bällebad ihr aussehen wird
allerdings da wir jetzt nur im auto
sitzen nach gefällt zwei stunden habe
ich mir gedacht dass jude mich da der
film könnte wie ich einige kommentare
von euch beantwortet
wie gar nichts getränk thorsten
lebensraum der fische zerstört sowie e
mails nach dringlichkeit schon macht
sich luka etwas eigentlich bestellt er
doch immer sein essen ja aber entwickelt
dass ich gerne und das sieht auch gerne
mal kaufen oder flop aber bitte lasst
das mit dem klo nicht immer auf die
leute gehen oder werden fakt ist hier
wird richtig gute profi eltern nicht
noch nicht
das ist schon mal ein trank machen wurde
bitte das wäre so cool wer will das auch
live ich glaube ich
natürlich seien 16 kriegen von junge und
gewicht keine kriege ich sie sehen will
sondern zurück und zweitens will ich
nicht so einen komischen selbst du mich
eigentlich zwei nicht zum komischen und
dann wieder und wieder fragen kanal
werden
da gibt es in amerika nele die das super
gemacht und deswegen stellt ihr euch
dann so vor du bist ein lappen luca
einfach nur dumm gefaxt so hart du
kannst du mal wieder auf etwas reagieren
hätte schon hart braucht mal wieder auf
irgendwas zu reagieren
sie sagt nur ich weiß derzeit nicht
genau auf was so die reaktionszeit war
es halt so dass die katen neuen song
rausgehauen bierdeckels verrücktes
gemacht haben irgendwie ist alles alles
geht seine wege jeder den vorderen und
alice cooper future aber falls hier
irgendwas denkt wo ich mal darauf
reagieren sollte dann für hersteller und
in die kommentare
ich hoffe mal so ein kleines auto und
fahrt durch die innenstadt naja
eigentlich hätte ich da bock drauf
kannst du ich wurde mal huckepack nehmen
[Musik]